one and all today i am going to talk
about my project on analysis of
hepatocellular carcinoma transcriptomic
data for drug repurposing
let me first of all introduce myself i
am sonalika ray i've done my masters in
bioinformatics from punjab university
chandigarh and my research interest lies
in omics data science computer aided
drug designing and pharmacoinformatics
so my topic is hepatocellular carcinoma
i'll be first of all shedding some light
on what it exactly is
so it is the second leading cause of
cancer related mortality globally
it is present in patients with chronic
liver inflammation associated with viral
infection alcohol overuse or metabolic
syndrome
a significant progress has been made in
ftc prevention diagnosis and treatment
in the past
it has been seen that more than 50
percent of all the hcc patients have a
diagnosis at an advanced stage that is a
stage b or higher and 70 percent of
patients relapse within the first five
years of initial treatment
early hcc is often resectable but
advanced hcc often requires soraphanep
for systematic treatment in addition to
local treatment with ablation
transactional chemoembolization or
external irradiation
solar phenomena is effective in
improving the outcomes of hcc patients
in the late stage initiating a period of
robust clinical research
but it has been observed that surah
fineb gains resistance in the later
stages so let's see what the mechanism
of fraction of surafinib drug is in fcc
sonaphanep is a multiple target tyrosine
kinase inhibitor that exhibits
anti-angiogenesis and anti-proliferation
effects and extended total median
survival in advanced hcc patients it
suppresses tumor cell
proliferation by inhibiting refined b
raf and kinase activity in the rash
draft
erk signaling pathways it is capable of
targeting the very three targets pdgfr
beta which fr2c kit and other proteins
to inhibit tumor and in geogenesis
lenward
have received approval as second line
treatments after sura phenip drug
immunotherapy for hcc has not yet been
approved in china or germany soropanib
remains a cornerstone treatment in hcc
that is supported by robust evidence and
clinical experience
so thirty percent of the patients they
get benefit from soraphanip and this
population usually acquires drug
resistance within 6 months
and also a role of epigenetics transport
processes regulated cell death and the
tumor micro environment in the
initiation and development of surafinib
resistance in fcc has been seen
so what are now what are those pathways
that could lead to heparic cellular
carcinoma and surface resistance
hepatocellular carcinoma so i'm going to
abbreviate these two terms throughout my
presentation as hcc and sr hcc
respectively
so you see there could be a number of
agents that could affect a number of
pathways leading to fcc it could be
because of aflatoxin alcohol also
chronic hepatitis
b or c could affect the pathways leading
to hcc
and to talk about the pathways that
could get affected uh which are
responsible for causing soraphanib
resistance in hcc
so soda phenebe is an anti-cancer drug
that is transported into the cell
through slc proteins
and inside the cell the drug is broken
down via various phases and cascade of
reactions
soda phenyp is a drug that is designed
to target multiple tyrosine kinase
inhibitors such as
vegf pdgf and also egf that activates
downstreams in signaling pathways such
as ras ras mk erk pathway
over expressed drug targets and
perpetually activated signaling pathways
will promote cell proliferation and
survival therefore promoting chemo
resistance
cellular pathways or processes such as
dna repair apoptosis and autophagy can
redirect their effect to promote cell
proliferation and survival rather than
cell death
i will also shed some light on the role
of map k signaling pathway and pi3k akt
pathway in causing the condition
so now talking about the research plan i
uh took two data sets they were from the
cell lines head g2 and hua7
matched the gene expression alteration
in resistant hcc with gene expression
changes caused by treatment of cancer
cells with drugs already fda approved
for other diseases
identified the drugs that could reverse
the resistance related changes and also
then identified their mechanism of
action
the pathways or the drug target involved
of the drug against hcc
and finally provide proof of concept
evidence for validity of the drug
repurposing approach with potential use
in personalized medicine
so the data sets that were taken were
two of them in the first data set the
samples were from a
normal population and the hcc patients
and the second data set had
samples from fcc patients and solar
phenom resistant fcc patients
now the first data set that was taken it
was evaluated for the differentially
expressed genes by
carrying out the various steps required
such as a normalization and then the
statistical tests including the
calculation of p value adjusted p value
and log fold change
and then the entries of uh the p values
the gene ids and the log fold change
values were altogether taken and
submitted on i length for further
evaluation
after the evaluation of
my entries of differentially expressed
genes and also the p values and the log
full change values i uh found out some
of my results that i'm going to share
with you on so this is the result for
transcription factor enrichment analysis
which tells that songs 2 and h and f 4a
are the most differentially expressed
transcription factors
and the kinase enrichment analysis
result shows that map k1 and map k3 are
again the most differentially expressed
kinases or we can also see that they are
statistically significant and
why are they now differentially
expressed is the question
and for the same data set i also found
out the protein protein interaction
expansion
where i found that esr1 is that one
protein which when affected would lead
to a casket of reactions to affect the
other proteins
and then the expression to kinesis
network is also shown very beautifully
here which shows that
when the
esr1 protein is stimulated it's actually
going to affect
these various proteins and also the
kinases that have been very well
mentioned
now what are the hub genes for hcc
so gpc3
was a particular gene that i found in
the gene linear result that actually
also affects a lot of other
differentially expressed genes that were
found in my data set
so now what is gpc3 gene all about it
positively regulates the canonical wntc
signaling pathway by binding to the wnt
receptor of result and stimulating the
binding of the fluid receptor to wnt
ligands
also the result was validated from
signet a uh
results that shows that afp
and gpc3 these two genes were the most
differentially expressed genes and also
are the main hub genes
right
after this
i took my results that was the list of
differentially expressed genes the gene
ids the p values to and the log full
change values to l 1000 cds square now l
1000 cds square is a links l 1000
characteristic direction signature
search engine it enables users to find
consensus l 1000 small molecule
signatures that match user input
signatures so my idea here was to
reverse the effect of our differentially
expressed genes
now l 1 000 c d square helps us with a
list of perturbations and combinations
that could be used effectively to
reverse the effect of differentially
expressed genes
now from the result of the very first
analysis of the very first data set i
know what are my differentially
expressed genes
proteins and kinases though i just took
the genes in consideration but i would
love to do my analysis with the
differentially expressed proteins and
kinases and ex2
and x2k expression network analysis as
well but yeah coming back to the the
differentially expressed genes i could
find out a list of perturbations and
combinations
which i further took to uh for further
analysis on pubchem
and also the drug bank to see
which are those perturbations which are
fda approved first of all
and also uh who have who follow the
lipidski's rule of five
right
the same particular gene set was taken
further for analysis and i
found the genes
so here we have all the genes and on top
we have all the perturbations now these
are those perturbations which are
actually going to reverse the effect of
these genes so here in this particular
graph the input gene signature is
depicted as the rows of the matrix and
the expression level of the genes are
indicated with red or blue label bars
indicating up or down
down expression
the top ranked is 1000 perturbations are
showed as columns with red label bars
and l 1000 perturbation gene signatures
are depicted as columns of the matrix
with red and blue squares indicating
their effect on the gene expression
so again from here here i could find out
the list of all those perturbations
which are actually reversing the effect
of our differentially expressed genes
now comes the second data set that was
uh that had the samples of swore up in a
resistant hcc patients and hcc patients
the same thing that was done for the
previous data set was done here as well
differentially expressed genes were
evaluated after running the
normalization and calculating various p
values adjusted p values log full change
values and then those values were taken
to l 1000 uh and i length again
so this is just a
screenshot that i want to share just to
show how the signatures are submitted
and it's very easy to just upload and
carry out uh the analysis
and uh here
i again found the transcription factors
that are differentially expressed that
include tp63 hn f4a
and kinases were the same map q1 and map
k3 again the differentially expressed
kinases
and
here smart 3 is that one protein
which one affected would lead to the
cassette of reactions to affect the
other proteins as well and is
statistically significant
and uh the expression to kinase's
expansion also shows that smart3 is that
one protein that is affecting or
interacting with a lot of differentially
expressed proteins and kinases
the hot genes for sonar solar panel
resistant paracellular carcinoma uh was
a major myof it is that one gene that
interacts with other crucial
differentially expressed genes which
leads to soraphinib resistance activity
in hepatocellular carcinoma
now uh again the perturbations and
combinations for the second data sets uh
were evaluated
and also uh so in total i got 30 to 40
of perturbations and some 20
combinations
and i checked for each of the molecules
activity and pubchem on drug bank and
yes did check if they orbited rule of
five and are fda approved or not
after all the analysis this is the list
of perturbations for normal versus
versus hcc
and uh the perturbations for src versus
hcc and here src is actually sort of in
a resistant clone versus hcc
and the list of combinations
now my idea here was
to pick those perturbations that are
actually common between normal and hcc
data set and a solar panel resistant and
fcc data set
just to make sure that the molecule or
the perturbation let's say that could be
repurposed could should be common for
both
the participations and the srcc patients
and same for the combinations
so i further went to veni and just
looked for the common perturbations and
combinations
this is the result what i got i got uh
10 perturbations that were actually
common between both of the data sets
now i studied the mechanism of action
for each one of the perturbation that
was common
so let's talk about the pathways in
brief
the first is cellulite
it is an orally active small molecule
with potential anteneoplastic activity
and it inhibits mk1 and 2 and prevents
the activation of
mek12dependent effector proteins and
transcription factors
thereby leading to an inhibition of
cellular proliferation in various
cancers
now if you remember i did say that we're
going to talk about the
affected pathways very soon in the
presentation
so now let's talk about afferent
that is the other perturbation that was
common in both the data sets aphrodineb
is an orally bioavailable allylino
quanazoline derivative
and inhibitor of the receptor tyrosine
kinase epidermal growth factor receptor
family with anti-neoplastic
activity
the third common perturbation was gifted
it is also an anilino qnazoline with
anti-neoplastic activity and it inhibits
the catalytic activity of numerous
thyroid kinases including the epidermal
growth factor receptor which may result
in inhibition of tyrosine
kinase-dependent tumor growth
specifically this agent competes with
the binding of atp to the tyrosine
kinase domain of egfr
thereby inhibiting receptor
autophosphorylation and resulting in
inhibition of signal transduction
gifternet may also enter into cell cycle
arrest and inhibit angiogenesis
the fourth common perturbation was
keratin that has a role as the tyrosine
kinase inhibitor and is an
antineoplastic
agent
lapatinib is a synthetic orally active
quinazoline with potential
antineoplastic properties it reversibly
blocks phosphorylation of the epidermal
growth factor receptor and also inhibits
cyclin d protein levels in human tumor
cell lines and xenograft
the last perturbation the second last
perturbation though was varinostat it is
a synthetic hydroxamic acid derivative
with anti-neoplastic activity and this
agent also induces apoptosis and
sensitizes tumor cells to cell death
processes varying stat crosses the blood
brain barrier
and the seventh uh perturbation
common was
mermaid
now why have i specifically written
about it separately
the reason being after getting all my
results i went through some of the
publications just to learn more about
these um
perturbations
and i uh got to know that these
perturbations are already in the
clinical trials to treat phone resistant
hcc
so yes i can call my project a case
study but my
goal here was to yes repurpose a drug
molecule so metamatina was that one
molecule or a perturbation about which i
could not find um more with respect to
it
it's being in clinical trial or so so
yes let's learn about medina
medina is an orally bioavailable
synthetic organic molecule that is
targeting
mitogen-activated protein kinase with
potential anti-neoplastic activity and
upon administration metamecinium
selectively binds to and inhibits mek
which may result in the inhibition of
phosphorylation and activation of um
mapkin jerking and inhibition of tumor
cell proliferation
the dual specific threonine tyrosine
kinase mek is a key
component of the ras rav mk erk
signaling pathway that is frequently
activated in human tumors
now
talking about the common combinations
between both of the data sets
so the results that i obtained were
selemeter net plus dlpdm uh mp
and me and meters andron the results of
dlpdmp
uh were not satisfactory when i uh took
it to pubchem and drug bank and that's
why i just fixed limited nip and
metoxantron to talk about that could be
used as an effective combination
to um
three thoracic resistance
in hcc patients
so the first uh
perturbation in the combination is
cellulite that inhibits oncogenic
downstream effects of the wrath
signaling pathway and these are the
interacting gene partners that i have
mentioned here on the slide
and then meter zantron is a potent
inhibitor of topoisomerase ii that is an
enzyme that is responsible for uncoiling
and repairing damaged dna and again the
interacting gene partners of meteos
androne have been mentioned here you can
pause the slide and refer to them if you
would want to
now what the conclusion of this project
would be
the conclusion is
that the drugs mentioned cilia metanaire
give it a nap after ten meters
could be used to overcome solar phenome
drug resistance as these drugs tend to
affect the pathways leading to cell
apoptosis now what other differential
expressed genes that were found uh have
been mentioned here gpc three afp lps uh
rps4 y1 mgll uh so being one my off map
1b igf-pp4
now our study was centered towards
repurposing drugs from differential
activity of genes
taking in account the differential
expression of genes and their role in
the affected pathway the drugs proposed
for repurposing have been mentioned
already so we show the feasibility of
the drug repurposing workflow by
validating novel drugs to use alone and
in combination with solar phenym
and the analysis uh here of the publicly
available gene expression data sets of
solar phenomena resistance models and
hcc patient data sets uh was done to
determine prioritized drug candidates
that may inform future additional
validation
studies
and i wish to study more about uh the
role of differentially expressed
transcription factors differentially
expressed kinases and also look at the
epigenetic effect
uh
that leads to souraphane resistance and
hcc
so that was it i am looking forward to
your feedback let me know in the chat
box if you have any feedback for me
thank